JD has I had no idea was a baseball card
collector
whatever and what is this safe you have
in your house I thought because there
you know early teens I thought it'd be
cool to have like a safe to keep like
you know who's in the safe I used what
you say I used to collect spoons like I
was younger when I was younger you know
people were like I think we you know
collect stamps and other things are
never has like you know maybe
interesting to collect spoons you know
no one really does that so what's your
best spoon like what's your go-to I
probably have one from Disneyland or
something Disney Minnie Mouse
oh you me so these aren't like regular
spoons they always I come from like a
state or a specific Disneyland you went
into the gift shop and you bought a
spoon and what was on the spoon look
more like a wooden spoon but not
wouldn't it was plastic and that's like
the be safe you got a plastic spoon and
you're safe might be valuable no no that
wasn't that wasn't at a value value
ability that was something interesting
though my 32 rookie car next to my value
[Laughter]
dispenser I say I used to have answers
to that was where a hoarder I don't know
I'm not a hoarder I mean I keep stuff
you have like one room in your whole
apartment well there's fancy it's
actually it's a three-bedroom there's a
three-bedroom but there's a lot of
people's stuff in there click [ __ ] spoon
do you ever take spoons from a
restaurant or anything now then get to
that those don't have value abilities